first question from at dean osborne 42
is kyler murray now the season mvp
front runner
there's one undefeated team left and the
pittsburgh steelers maybe ben
roethlisberger would be the candidate
from there russell wilson was kyler
murray beats him is kyler right now the
favorite shireen
yeah i'm not going with collar on the
favorite but i do think he's in that
discussion mike when you look at russell
wilson he has 22 touchdown passes right
that ties the record through six games
peyton manning had also had 22. i just
think he's playing at elite level
thought kyler played better than he did
yesterday with the three interceptions
that that russell wilson
threw and he keeps having a performances
like that we are going to start talking
about him but i would i would say
russell wilson aaron rodgers uh tom
brady patrick mahomes and you mentioned
ben roethlisberger and perhaps ryan
tannehill or or derek henry we talked to
derek henry about that last week and and
he wants ryan tannehill in that
conversation but those are all good
candidates i don't know if there's a
favorite like we were talking about
russell wilson the favorite favorite
favorite favorite now that he's lost
this game to color murray it's kind of
tempered that a little bit but i still
think
russell wilson is still my favorite at
this point i think the key is this and
we won't know until the end of the
season we typically won't know until the
end of week 17 possibly all the way up
until the final game the one seeds have
to get locked in once we know the one
seeds in each conference the
quarterbacks of the two one seeds are
the most likely mvps unless somebody
just blows away every statistical
category like it's a derrick henry
breaking eric dickerson's record like
adrian peterson did in 2012 to to beat
peyton manning for the award so one seed
is going to be the key the quarterback
of the one seed whether it's tom brady
russell wilson kyler murray aaron
rodgers or in the afc whoever the one
seed is patrick mahomes if that's how it
shakes out that's where your your
regular season mvp favorite comes from
next one at m haddad 715 which one of
the four nfc west teams is the least
likely to make the playoffs i think all
four of them can if one is out who's out
shireen
it's hard to say mike i mean do we even
know much about these teams outside of
seattle just because they've beat up on
the nfc east i mean that's been the
division that they've played this year i
really don't know anything about the
rams i can't tell you if i want to pick
a least favorite i mean i've tried to
write off the 49ers for three or four
times this year and they just keep
coming back from the dead i'm going to
go with the 49ers but the way kyle
shanahan's coaching and what john lynch
has done with that roster is nothing
beyond unbelievable and if they can keep
going it's not going to surprise you
they make the plows but i'm going to go
with 49ers just because of all the
injuries they've had
i'll say the rams because again their
four wins are against the nfc east and
we'll find out more about the rams
tonight when they play the chicago bears
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports